its name means Smoky Mountain right now
it's living up to it
pop a catapital a five and a half
thousand meter volcano in central Mexico
currently belching out poisonous Smoke
and Ashes
the government's volcano meter is one
step away from prepared to evacuate
they're getting shelters ready for the
more than 120 000 people in the danger
zone for those we met in San Pedro
Benito Juarez almost at the foot of the
volcano occurring on as normal they have
a different way of looking at it
when we have a few months with no smoke
and no noise that's when we worry we
think what's happening with the volcano
it has to breathe
in reality yes
Amelia's family Farmers accept the
trade-off the volcano brings fertile Ash
enrich soil versus the always lingering
risk of Destruction
we have to take the good with the bad
she tells me
but the clouds of smoke and dash already
affecting nearby towns too schools are
out because of the contaminated air face
masks are back and the locally famous
flowers of nearby lisco currently look
like this nothing's Escaping The Ash
carpet and clearing it away is a
cecipian task
every day we have to sweep it up it
really affects us we have a business
selling ice lollies and we have to keep
it closed
the ash cloud is actually so thick that
we haven't even been able to see the
volcano for most of our visit it's
hidden somewhere over there and that
cloud has traveled far enough away that
it's even closed down Mexico City
airport for a few hours this Saturday
despite the Merc scientists have kept
their eye on public day and night in
this special Monitoring Center a full
eruption is what they fear though they
stress that isn't the situation yet
there's a lot of Ash but will aren't at
the point of a red alert
those in the volcano Shadow are leaving
the authorities to it for them it's
business as usual John Holman Al Jazeera
San Pedro Benito Juarez Mexico